in a recent Niche video topic that I
didn't think anyone would watch
pleasantly surprised me wrong I covered
a substantial amount of video game
crossovers with the newly resurrected
Dead Space franchise I just kept going
further down the rabbit hole to realize
Isaac Clark the main character of dead
space Maybe in more video games other
than his own series than any other
character in gaming I thought I was as
thorough as I possibly could be however
I checked the comments out have fearing
that they'd make fun of me for playing
video games with my mom but they're
actually really kind about that but of
course there were dozens of comments
pointing out that I missed one
and all of those comments were saying
different games so I sat down and made a
new list of everything you guys
commented had an Isaac appearance and
for some of you who complained that I
was a little too wordy last time I've
also decided to speed up the pace for
this one because I'm a people pleaser by
including the Duke Nukem and Battlefield
Hardline Easter eggs I open a whole can
of worms by counting just his helmet as
an appearance and as it turns out for a
character that rarely ever removes his
helmet he's ironically leaving them all
across the Multiverse in various places
either for other playable characters to
pick up and throw around like a weird
bucket or to put on themselves plus of
course a few actual fully playable Isaac
appearances as well the original video
had at least 18 games and there's still
more I can't be totally sure if even now
I'm still missing some so leave a
comment below if I'm still missing any
from this list at this point I wouldn't
be surprised if this guy's in Dr Mario
by the way just for making it easier for
people to research this stuff in the
future I expect that fan Wiki pages are
going to be updated to reflect all these
since they typically only list one or
two appearances out of the
I think we're up to 30ish now get on
that whoever runs those so let's look at
all the other Isaac Clark appearances
and Games With a Little Help from you
the viewer
but first a brief word from today's
sponsor in 2020 there were over 5
million car crashes that's more than 15
000 a day and six hundred an hour just
back in December my own dad slid off an
icy Road and broke his hip in four
places and the thought of getting legal
help was so daunting for him
those in an accident can be entitled to
more than you think when something like
that happens it's always good to have
someone in your corner looking out for
your best interest someone like the fine
folks at Morgan and Morgan if you've
been in an accident there are certain
things you need to do make sure you're
okay make sure you get a police report
make sure you contact your insurance and
make sure you get legal representation
so if you're injured and don't know
where to start with Morgan and Morgan
it's so easy Morgan and Morgan have
modernized injury law by making the
process as easy and streamlined as
possible so you can submit a claim in
eight clicks or less no need for you to
visit law offices and sit through timely
consultations you can submit a claim and
have a lawyer review your case and get
started on helping you right away you
can submit your case details sign
contracts upload documents and medical
records all from your cell phone and you
can even text your attorney and legal
team throughout the duration of your
case with Morgan and Morgan you can
submit a claim without ever having to
leave the couch if you're ever injured
in an accident you can check out Morgan
and Morgan for more information go to
forthepeople.com or pound law that's
pound529 from your cell phone now back
to the video
a lot of people brought this one up
which is funny because I've never even
heard of this game before now this is
one of those fortnite style fear of
missing out games with limited release
windows for downloadable additions but
unlike fortnite this one is going
offline super soon because I guess it
just wasn't making the bank to justify
indefinite service and updates
well I'm not going around lately Isaac's
helmet is wearable for players in the
game added during a special Halloween
event in 2021 and it was modeled by
artist Sebastian Gatt who posted some
behind the scenes stuff for it on his
art station it's a shame this game's
going offline soon I have no idea what
the goal even is but the art style is
nice and the gameplay looks fun maybe
try to check it out before it's gone in
June special thanks to my buddy Diego
Rivera for recording this one for me
this whole game is like a big Dead Space
reference so it's only fitting after a
dead space-esque gory Alien Invasion is
successfully repelled you gotta wonder
who gets paid to clean up all that blood
and guts well you of course
in this game you can run around piling
up limbs mopping up the various fluids
of war and picking up shell casings
spent mowing down extraterrestrial
combatants I love funny game Concepts
like this so I want to check this one
out sometime this game's full of Easter
eggs for other franchises but in one
particular level you can pull this out
of the bushes and see for yourself that
this guy really needs to hold on to that
thing tighter
in the epicenter multiplayer map during
the heat of battle you can knock down
this wall because of the Nifty
destructible environments and find the
Dead Space 2 Advanced suit helmet
resting on a Shelf
still staying in the realm of
Battlefield Battlefield Heroes was a
2009 multiplayer only spin-off for the
series that went for a more stylized
graphical approach
naturally in 2011 to coincide with dead
space 2's release they added the
advanced suit and security suit as
Cosmetics kind of weird pick usually
it's the advanced suit and the
Engineering Suit that gets picked for
things like this I like seeing unique
models created for these crossovers too
instead of just porting ones from actual
Dead Space
Isaac in this art style looks a little
bit more like a tf2 character with his
thin ankles and bulky midsection so it's
really fun to see
much like PlayStation home this is
another Dead game that was shut down in
2015 but there's also a dedicated fan
project to revive it called Rising Hub
and since these two videos seem to dip
into lost media archival and gaming
preservation I think it's only fair to
link them in the description too and
tell you to go support that project any
way you can
Angus got this footage
so Isaac was in the PSP Port of 40th day
but he's also in the third Army of Two
army of two three
which you know this is the one that I
never played because I only cared about
Salem and Rios and when it stopped being
those guys I was like whatever but this
game is actually
full of wearable dead space helmets for
just for the fun of it I guess you've
got the Dead Space 2 engineering helmet
Dead Space 3 survival suit helmet and
Carver's stupid generic looking whatever
the [__] ever cared for Carver's default
look in Dead Space 3 by the way with his
slight redesign of the level 6 suit he's
not horizontal enough in the face you
know Roblox adds unlicensed stuff by
just calling it something else so you
can wear the space battle helmet in
securebot 8990 helmets in that game I
don't know what the hell Pixel Gun 3D is
but there's an Isaac in there God that
helmet sure gets around it's even a
little pendant you can attach to your
gun in Apex Legends I don't think any
word better describes this character
than space man and unfortunate bogus so
this isn't technically an official
appearance because they didn't get the
rights to make this so it's a crossover
in the same way as all the legally
distinct characters in broforce
it's called the Newton suit
except he's named after Isaac Asimov not
Isaac Newton but either way this costume
looks great unfortunate Spaceman is a
multiplayer space themed horror who done
it that is laid out like another popular
game turned meme where Spacemen have
their tasks while an imposter tries to
sabotage the crew though while recording
this footage Angus ran into some dead
ends with that mode the issue is no one
could really play it unless they have
like a lot of friends gathered to do it
and as the public servers are currently
a ghost town it only works with more
than six players in a private server and
otherwise the multiplayer for this game
is totally dead the other two game modes
are a little tacked on so the Among Us
style mode is pretty much the main draw
and if that doesn't work kind of screwed
the Dead Space costume looks really good
though unfortunately
you can't change the pallet swaps around
to achieve the actual blue lights and
bronze armor look because the color
palette of the lights is tied to the
color of the armor itself but it's still
a great take on the design avoiding that
particular color combination is probably
what keeps this DLC costume from being
sued into Oblivion I saved this one for
last because it's the one that took the
most effort on my part to unlock in
researching the first video I saw a Wiki
page that said Isaac had been cut from
this game and assumed that meant he
wasn't in it but a few people pointed
out that he actually was in my Sims
agents he just wasn't a character you
could talk to slash interact with and
cut scenes however they did add the
costume unfortunately this is another
one of those no one on the entire
internet seems to have filmed sort of
things so it was up to me in the Wii U I
borrowed from my 11 year old sister who
is now 15. my Sims agents is a Charming
little Adventure game where you roam
around locations solving simple
Mysteries and chasing Clues and various
investigations
something to do with this evil
billionaire with a name that reminds me
of morbius and a face that reminds me of
Baron mordo well I guess he also looks a
little bit like Razzle ghoul after
playing for three hours you can get to
the top of this mountain on the ski
lodge area and dig up a peculiar looking
ski suit in the snow he had to do a
costume change location and behold the
cutest little space engineer he ever
done seen it's a shame I now no longer
have any interest to follow up with the
rest of this game's story after this but
I did enjoy what little timeout I played
on the road to this costume
if you recall last time I also asked
viewers out there in the community to
try to add Isaac Clark to even more
games just to keep the meme of him being
everywhere going and someone actually
got to work on one one of my patrons for
me on patreon too by the name of tubular
Spaceman decided to Port Isaac over to
Ultimate Alliance
and ask for my help as an advisor so we
workshopped a good moveset for him I
captured sound effects for his weapons
and moves
[__] you
foreign
Dead Space game and get a decent amount
of voice clips so he's a fully voiced
character that works just the same as
any official in-game playable character
never underestimate an engineer
[Music]
the mod has so much time and love put
into it and I gotta say Spaceman did a
fantastic job because it feels just like
Isaac's an official DLC character check
the link in the description so you can
download him for the 2006 edition of
Ultimate Alliance and check it out
and for the rest of you with the skills
and prowess let's keep it going add them
to more games give him fully functioning
weapons and voice lines and whatever
else
it's fun to see where he could go next
how about one of the Lego games I said
halo or Half-Life last time oh put him
in Resident Evil 2. why not the remake
or the original why not both
since it's a virtual certainty because
God damn this guy gets around what other
games has he showed up in that I haven't
mentioned in this or the previous video
and would you like to see this become a
sort of Series where we highlight
another crossover prone character with
each new installment what characters
could ever hope to compare to Isaac's
list
maybe Master Chief has gotten around
more than you'd realize
who knows must investigate further
I always get mad at YouTube for not
putting my videos in the subscription
box because people will comment finally
Xavier uploads again after all these
years not knowing three other videos
came out within the last month already
so maybe that stupid Bell icon thing
will help you remember I exist if you
want other ways to support the channel
you can always go hit up that patreon
for early videos and exclusive stuff
because it's just a dollar I'm not
kidding it's only one dollar Isn't that
cool if everyone who watched this video
donated one dollar a month I'd be able
to afford a house for myself so that
would be that would be really cool you
can also check out our merch on T public
or just buy some of my random stuff on
eBay I have a pretty substantial
collection of old toys that are still in
the box in perfect condition so go take
a look in case you find something you
like and lastly since this is a YouTube
video and you probably play fortnite
drop my Creator quote Xavier GM next
time you buy a silly dancer cool
character skin really helps me out
see you next time
foreign